liebe freunde ich bin heute zum ersten
mal clash of plants chips vor sieben
jahren schon mal gespielt aber da kann
ich nicht überhaupt nicht mehr daran
erinnern und er schickt dieses video
gern selbstverständlich an euren
freunden die auch cash auf kleinen
spielen und einen kanal wenn ihr weitere
videos nicht verpassen wollte
willkommen häuptling wir haben schon auf
dich gewartet alles klar brigitte was
gibt es noch wie es ist ein neues dorf
das leben wäre wirklich perfekt wenn es
da nicht
was
war was ist das noch ein mickriges
menschlein
wir müssen jetzt eine kanone bauen und
unser dorf zu verteidigen ich setze sie
einfach mal hierhin hier vorne hin
ganzen damit wir auf sniper basis die
ganzen kobolde wächst können du kannst
ein paar juwelen ausgeben um die sache
zu beschleunigen auf gar keinen fall
wir sparen doch schön es gibt ja andere
youtuber die stecken hier unfassbar viel
geld in diese spielerei und läutet remax
hier aber ich sage euch ich werde hier
gar keinen cent ausgeben gerade kobolde
angriff
also das macht mir wirklich keine angst
bin ich ganz ehrlich aber gut die kommen
jetzt auf jeden fall an und fahren
laufen zu meiner kann ohne direkt im
system oder das war knapp danke heutling
wir müssen jetzt selber angreifen das
heißt ich jetzt einfach mal hier drei
magier hin von jeder seite die
attackieren jetzt das haus da und was
ist mit der kanone ab man die kanone die
karosserie aufhalten
dies macht brutal spaß das spiel habt
geht zurück nach hause wo auch gut
gemacht jetzt müssen wir dieses dorf für
den kampf rüsten indem du einen weiteren
bauarbeiter an heute ist
die kost 250 juve muss kredite aufnehmen
setzen wir die bauhütte einfach mal hier
direkt neben die andere kacke mit elixir
kannst du truppen ausbilden und gebäude
bauen du kannst nix die aus dem boden
pumpen ach guck mal hier wie so eine
ölraffinerie tag setzen wir direkt
vornehmen die goldmine ja du willst will
dass ich es beenden aber nehme
ich bin schlau ich spare geld das auch
ohne geld fertig
es wird schon ein bisschen epischer sein
können ich bin jetzt elixier gruben bau
gräber aus boden raus
[Musik]
jetzt soll ich auch ein elixier lager
bauen das kommt natürlich
selbstverständlich direkt hier neben
damit die nicht schon langen weg haben
die kleinen kobolde die das für mich
macht in die kobolde sind ja nicht die
sind ja nu
crew-mitglieder
alles von mir so geist der die bringt
als wenn ich habe geschafft hätte im
goldlager brauchen wir
selbstverständlich auch das setzen wir
dann selbstverständlich neben das gold
direkt ich denke an die leute
dass sie nicht zwei kilometer mit zehn
tonnen gold laufen müssen so wie meine
leute hier in hamburg für mich
red schon wieder acht gold deko bolte
lieben gold
war klar
kommt die sind diese kobolde die visana
aussehen sind wie das finanzamt der
pause einmal im goldlager comdirect an
wir lieben gold eine kaserne die setzen
wir direkt daneben die anderen hütten
von den leuten damit die da so ein
bisschen chillen können wir das auch süß
wer das baute er klopfte einfach gegen
oder sind drei sekunden 21
und jetzt lasst uns ein paar truppen aus
bild ruppen ausbilden ich will nicht im
krieg aber gut brigitte klicke ich mal
auf truppen ausbilden nehmen wir hier
die standard barbaren mal hier können
wir uns hier so viel licht viel
ausbilden
ich hab ne ne ne ne ne ich werde hier
nichts ausgeben warten und tee trinken
erst fertig oder der
[Musik]
er wird mein elixier nehmen oder oder
wochen ist ja davon positionen
doch der mag einfach nur das lagerfeuer
sieht doch so aus als wäre das hier
extrem kühl comedy sind direkt am meer
jungen können ein bisschen chillen
schwimmen gehen was das
schiff
in norwegen tour machen sechs minuten
dauert der bums noch hat seine cousins
geholt weil er da wieder heran also
kriegen wir da unten links auf angriff
greifen wir hier den kobold wald an ich
weiß nicht warum leute meine lieben
kobolde ich will eigentlich nicht aber
könnt euch mal hier bist hier
kann's im roten mit einer truppe setzen
dann habe ich jetzt acht truppen
ausgegeben nur damit sind acht von den
einst cousins nur damit die dass sie
angreifen kriegt die auch wieder zurück
oder sagen wir mal ein bisschen besser
machen r1 greift an der eine turm ist 1
1 bleibt das rote haus zusammen mit
seinem bruder heinz die beiden cousins
11 und heinz einen lochstreifen standard
den dritten stern fantastisch meine
lieben freunde
wie können so viele milliarden menschen
dieses spiel spielen das war ein toller
kampf
wie soll man sich in unserer geschichte
an dich erinnern als checker mekka 4000
euro sagst du bringst du wirst mir
bestimmt gleich so auch so
es geht nicht weiter
40 mein gott ok fertig mit dem gold dass
wir den kobolden abgenommen haben können
wir es uns leisten rathaus zu verbessern
schätzt der architekt nerd zehn sekunden
dauert das nur jetzt beenden
ich habe hier alles mal so ein bisschen
angepasst denn mein rathaus steht jetzt
direkt in der mitte dann habe ich hier
das elixier lager und das goldlager
hingestellt hier die goldminen hier den
elixir sammler jeder unsere beiden
bauhütten die kanone kann von hier vorne
alles mal müssen wochen habe ich erst
mal bisschen aufbessern
wir haben hier jedoch ein paar
herausforderungen und zwar brauchen wir
noch eine kaserne erstmal von daher gehe
ich jetzt unten in den shop nehmen wir
eine kaserne und setzt sie jetzt einfach
mal ihr neben des gold links da müssen
wir das ja auch schon abgedeckt haben an
die das ist erst wenn es fertig ist dann
müssen wir 4000 goldenen einzelspieler
oder mehr spieler kämpfen ja dann ab zum
angriff
los geht's
das ist ja oft auch
hier trat haus elixir lager goldmine
okay da wir direkt darauf leute wir
gehen alle natürlich direkt auf rathaus
damit wir hier direkt den linkscanner
lebens ein bisschen gold mit hier ab zum
lager und hier zum elixir noch zweiter
in sekunden später
das macht richtig spaß haufe einen
bogenschützen um kein problem brigitte
wenn im bogenschützen turm haben bild
gehen wir natürlich hier direkt zum
bogenschützen tun haben wir nämlich
genau
da ist guck mal hier bogenschützen tun
wir machen das einfach mal so der kommt
hier hin da machen wir allerdings das
endlager ein bisschen weiter weg so dass
der porsche zentrum hierhin kann sagt
der sammler hier hin dass armee lagen
hat dort hin die das passt jetzt
wiederum nicht dann machen wir das
einfach anders weil dann kommt das hier
einfach hier vorne hin guck mal die hat
sie laufen daher was ist wenn ich jetzt
so woche
trainieren die etwa einfach ein bisschen
er wird hat man seinen spaß ihr kommt
auf jeden fall wieder hier vorne hin die
kleinen heinzelmännchen wir fordern mit
den bogenschützen tun das heißt ich habe
die herausforderung jetzt auch
abgeschlossen perfekt aber geschafft wir
benötigen noch 1
22 mio
ich kann auch eine mauer um den kollegen
hier umbauen oder was wusste dass hier
guck mal sogar seine stabile mit spitzen
[Musik]
da gibt es wie bei jeder mauer sollen
sound
[Musik]
mehr morgen kann ich nicht bauen
weil mein rathaus höher sein muss
perfekt jetzt ist die aufnahme
abgestürzt von daher würde ich an der
stelle jetzt zwangsläufig auch mein
erstes mal clash of plants seit sieben
jahren beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch das video hier gefallen hat dann
lasst doch gern einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier daneben kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr einen weiteren
teil von claire schafft es mit luca
sehen wollt ich habe absolut gar kein
bauer